ouais hier j'ai eu beaucoup trop pour le
déjeuner sept hamburgers 3-3 avocats
Havens
[Musique]
Je ne me sens pas aussi bien si je ne fais pas d'
exercice je fais si je le fais je me sens
mieux je me sens plus en forme je me sens  Je pense que
c'est une bonne compensation pour aucune autre
raison cela vous permet de bien mieux compenser dans la
vie et
bien vous êtes en forme alors
vous pouvez faire d'autres choses vous pouvez rester debout
plus tard boire plus de vin et ne pas que cela
vous dérange  cuisinez-vous juste des
choses simples que je peux faire des omelettes des hamburgers
et des sortes de choses
spectaculaires ici est détective c'est un
hamburger nos hamburgers Dirty Harry ils l'
appellent ici à l'inspiration des câlins et
la différence est qu'il est juste un
peu plus gros le meilleur  de la viande et je ne suis pas le
chef normal mais de temps en temps
j'entre et j'en prépare un pour moi-même
tu es un gros mangeur ouais
hier j'ai eu beaucoup trop pour le déjeuner
sept hamburgers trois trois
paradis d'avocat et puis j'ai couru  30 pieds et
effondré
[Musique]